these people doing jiu jitsu to try to
say mcconnell isn't changing anything
you know because what he
what he said at the one time but not in
all the other interviews was that when
it's
when it's divided government when it's
like a sitting democrat
in the white house and the republicans
and then now that the senators are
coming out like well here's all the
numbers to the number of times that
look it's a reversal by the republicans
but
crimea river for the democrats are upset
over it because
they are the ones who started this
judicial war i've been following the
court for a long time and practicing law
for a long time too
and this started back when they borked
robert four
speaking of uh of ruth bader ginsburg
and everything that's going on with the
supreme court right now
you tweeted out something that i thought
was just like so you framed
it so correctly which is that's you
basically said
and you can clean it up for me but in
essence you were saying like look
everybody's sort of a hypocrite here and
you can sort of catch everybody saying
the reverse
when they're not in power but but this
is
just how politics works it it just sort
of is
and i think that's what most people i
think kind of see right now it's like
we can all look back on videos of biden
saying the reverse and harrah's saying
the reverse and mcconnell's saying the
reverse like
it's across the board but then there's
also just like the reality of politics
and if you've got the power
you're going to use it these people
doing
jiu jitsu to try to say mcconnell
isn't changing anything you know because
what he
what he said at the one time but not in
all the other interviews was that when
it's
when it's divided government when it's
like a sitting democrat
in the white house and the republicans
and then now that the senators are
coming out like well here's all the
numbers these are the number of times
that
look it's a reversal by the republicans
but
crimea river for the democrats are upset
over it because
they are the ones who started this
judicial war i've been following the
court for a long time and practicing law
for a long time too
and this started back when they borked
robert prior to that the standard was to
confirm
any reasonable jurist you you knew
republican
presidents were going to pick
conservative leaning justices uh
democratic ones were going to pick more
liberal-leaning ones and in the end it
balances out
then then robert ford came up and they
said no way
he's too conservative he's not getting
on and that that was the first time that
changed
and then miguel estrada who was
a star lawyer who they wanted to elevate
the republicans wanted him um
on this dc circuit court of appeals and
the democrats were quoted as saying they
were they were afraid of him because
he was this dynamic um hispanic
rising star in the republican party and
they didn't want him because they knew
he'd make
the supreme court someday and they held
up his nomination his confirmation
hearings
for two years to the point where the guy
finally had to say i i withdraw like i
gotta get on with my life support my
family
they started that and that's why later
mitch mcconnell
started to slow roll barack obama's
judges
that led to harry reid saying i'm doing
the nuclear option
screw you we're getting rid of the
filibuster the republicans stood up and
said if you get rid of the filibuster on
lower court judges we're going to do the
same to you on supreme court judges if
we ever take power in the senate again
then the american electorate put the
republicans in charge of the senate and
mitch mcconnell was true to his word
i mean it's it ain't beanbag right and
it's ugly and it's gonna get even uglier
i i don't predict
anything kind or good happening over the
next
six months when it comes to the supreme
court yeah
do you sense there's any way we can get
out of this thing i mean putting aside
whether it's just about supreme court
just like
everything that everyone feels so crazy
all the time that politics is everywhere
all the time
that it seems like half the people want
to burn it down and
the other the other half according to
them are all racists anyway like
do you see a path to getting out of it
i sadly i think the only thing that
would do it anytime soon is some sort of
national
tragedy you know and i don't mean like
hovind i mean
a war you know um obviously i'm not
wishing for that i'm just saying
it takes something truly massive like
that to
bring the country together and as tough
as corona has been it too has been
politicized
and it hasn't had the horrific shock
value
you know in an instant the way say a 911
did or i'm sure pearl harbor did
where you're just like holding on to
humanity and looking at your fellow
human beings with a little bit more
kindness
um i don't know i've often thought okay
trump is definitely such an unusual
leader
right and he's divisive of course but
i don't think this goes away if donald
trump loses this election i think trump
was
definitely a a a result
of our increasing partisanship and you
know the republicans wanted and needed a
fighter
and they're not really concerned that he
doesn't speak the queen's english
and isn't necessarily you know the
perfect husband and you know he's he's
had some moral failings of course
um so i don't think even if he if he's
gone whether it's joe biden or somebody
else another even another republican in
the office
it gets better until we're reminded of
what matters
what why do these people have so much
time and i can say this because i'm a
woman
to focus on their gender right like why
how they're being discriminated against
as a woman how like i know
they'll say because we are you know
we're victims
i don't believe that because i have
other women to talk to and i have other
black men to talk to and i have other
trans
friends to talk to who don't run around
looking for ways in which they've been
victimized all day every day
they're strong they leave their lives
they suffer some adversity like we all
do
time to time they forge forward they
take life lessons from it they move on
like the amount of naval gazing that
goes on
in figuring out what identity do i have
that
will allow me to embrace the victim
ideology is a total
waste of time yeah well it's miserable
it won't get you anywhere and look
even for you it's not that being a woman
in the news business is the easiest
thing i mean
bombshell is sort of sort of about that
um but you pretty much just kept moving
forward
and it basically worked well i don't
i've never liked to think of myself as a
victim and
i recognize that doesn't mean i i've
never been one right like
i i had i had a terrible stalker a
felonious
stalker in my life who went to prison
for a very long time after he stalked me
and um and i have been bullied by some
very powerful
figures but i never call myself a victim
i always call myself a target right like
i was a target of that doctor and i was
target of certain people and that's fine
i can get past that
like eventually you're not a target
anymore and
if the more like you get ensconced
in that woe is me ideology even
if you deserve it even if
you do deserve empathy and you have been
victimized the worse
it is for you you know it just leads to
a
constant cyclone of negativity sadness
anger around you and you you've got to
as a gift to yourself
pull yourself out of that i don't know i
don't care if it's cognitive behavioral
therapy where you just got to think of a
picture of your dog
like do do whatever you need to do to
get yourself out of that
when you don't it leads to bad things in
your life your happiness level goes down
not up
right if you just think of yourself as
victimized all the time
so i don't i don't understand why more
people don't get that i think people are
sort of looking for a reason
to feel victimized to find their posse
you know like to feel like they're
bonded to other people in the same
position
i think this is why women get mad at me
when i won't say i'm a feminist you know
they want me in the posse and they don't
get my stiff arm on some of their
favorite
words um but i find the other the
opposite
world view much more conducive to
success
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell